I love movies so being able to work on  the types of films that I grew up  watching it's sort of a dream come true  I love working at imax and I think it's  the people more than anything that make  us unique you know you go around and  meet the team in all the different  offices in different countries  everywhere you turn you see you know the  best in their field and that's from you  know the mathematicians all the way to  the team in marketing you know  everyone's on their game imax sets the  bar very very high everything we do just  has to be the best what we do you know  for imax we feel that we contribute not  only to the brand but also to the film  industry just being able to be part of  that and knowing that what you  contribute and your ideas are taking  seriously and they can actually you know  come to life and that's so encouraging  and it also makes you feel part of  something special  you